we've got a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p you can call
it any time of day here's what a caller
had to say to us
hi david and hat i watch your show every
day i love you guys i watch lots of
progressive on youtube and i always face
like who what i want online i like the
date team and you're definitely one
because of your amazing ability to
remain calm and patient when dealing
with the most imperii a ting people it's
amazing how did you learn such
incredible patience um anyway thank you
and keep up the good work well listen I
appreciate the compliment I never
formally participated in any kind of
debate pad let me get that out there how
did I learn patience I don't know I feel
like patience is something that you can
learn but that by and large you're
predisposed to like I've always had a
very unwavering attention span that was
always my key trait growing up I could
really focus on stuff I'm the opposite
of ADHD I think you just solve also
interviewed so many right-wingers so at
this point you're just kind of used to
it well do that either peace there's
that and there's also no advantage to
just yelling and playing point
counterpoint to the point where you
don't even move the conversation forward
and sometimes we're criticized for that
right hey David you didn't refute the
ten things that Richard Spencer lied
about or distorted within one minute
well no if I had done that that would
have been the end of the interview I
would have spent the rest of the
interview just talking about that and
and this is why the tactic of the Gish
Gallup is very effective if you haven't
heard that one look it up the Gish
Gallup but anyway I participated on this
callers debate team is the voicemail
caller suggesting that you would make
for a master debater a very good
question a very very good question one
that we will save the answer up to for
the bonus show as end of an argument to
take a quote out of today's hate reo
mail on the bonus show today the 1% are
washing their money
crushing it not laundering it not
bleaching it like Donald Trump once said
Hillary Clinton with their hard drives
but the 1% are washing their money
through arts funding I will explain how
Hawaii has become the first US state to
pass a bill supporting basic income and
we have a parole hearing set for OJ
Simpson in that kidnapping and armed
robbery case for which he is serving
time in prison we will learn not only
about that but also where was producer
Pat when the verdict to the original OJ
Simpson murder trial was announced you
might be surprised to hear the answer to
that david pakman.com slash membership
that is the one and only way that you
can sign up for membership and get
instant access to the bonus show the
david pakman show bonus show available
every single day to paid subscribers
sign up and remember to 192 david p is
our voicemail number call any time of
day talk to you tomorrow